اشتذبت ليالي الفيلم السعودي التي اقيم في
فرنسا عددا كبيرا من الجمهور الذي قدم
للتعرف على الفن السعودي السينمائي
ومشاهدته الفعاليه شملت عروضا للافلام
وحلقات نقاشيه وتفاعليه وجالت اربع مدن
فرنسيه من ضمنها باريس واليوم وشاركت
السعوديه بعدد من الافلام المميزه منها
فيلم عثمان والذي يحكي قصه حارس بوابه
مستشفى تتغير معه الاحداث بشكل مفاجئ ما
يجبره على مواجهه الواقع الفيلم من اخراج
خالد زيدان
الجوائز الدوليه والمحليه وهو ضيفنا اليوم
في صباح العربيه معنا من جازان او ينضم
الينا المخرج خالد زيدان صباح الخير خالد
يا اهلا وسهلا صباح النور يعطيكم العافيه
يعني السؤال اللي تسالته قبل ما نبدا
الفقره شعرت ولاول وهله ان الفيلم عباره
عن قصه حقيقيه هل شعوري بمحله
خلينا نقول القصه ما هي حقيقيه او ما هي
مستوحاه من الواقعه وقصه حدثت فعلا لكن
نوع الفيلم فيلم واقعي وانا مهتم جدا
بالافلام الواقعيه اللي هي اسلوب الاخراج
في واسلوب حكايه القصه فيه واقعي ويشبه
الواقع نعم خالد انا اللي اثار فضولي
واللي شفتها البارحه على التويتات على
حسابك انه الكل يسال انه ليش فرنسا تحديدا
فرنسا لاطلاق هذا الفيلم
طبعا هيئه الافلام السعوديه اختارت فرنسا
واختارت عدد من الافلام السعوديه القصيره
للعرض في فرنسا او في
في مناسبه ليالي الفيلم السعودي اختارت
فرنسا تحديدا لانه فرنسا معروفه
بصناعه الافلام
واول فيلم او اول فيلم متحرك في العالم
تصور في فرنسا
صحيح
فرنسا من يعني من من عشرات السنوات وهم
مهتمين بالسينما وبصناعه السينما والمجتمع
الفرنسي بشكل عام عنده ذائقه سينمائيه
عاليه فهي فرصه جدا جيده لتبادل ثقافات
ولمشاركه الثقافه مختلفه جدا
وعرض افلام سعوديه قصيره
لمجتمع سينمائي
يعني خالد الجمهور او المشاهد الفرنسي يعد
ناقدا جيدا للسينما كيف كانت تفاعل ان كان
بباريس او اليوم او مدن فرنسيه اخرى مع
الفيلم هذا الفيلم السعودي
صحيح نقطه مهمه الافلام السعوديه القصيره
ومن ضمنها فيلم عثمان عرضت في ثلاث مناطق
مختلفه ابتداء بباريس بصراحه انا قبل عروض
الافلام ما كنت متخوف كثير لانه الافلام
انعرضت في دول مختلفه قبل او فيلم عثمان
تحديدا نعرض في السعوديه وفي الخليج وفي
دول اخرى فما كان في تخوف كبير ولكن كان
في نقطه يعني
مازلت اجهلها قبل ما اسافر اللي هو هلا
المجتمع الفرنسي راح
يستقبل او يتلقى الفيلم بنفس الطريقه اللي
تلقاها المجتمع السعودي او المجتمع
الخليجي هل راح توصلوا الفكره لانه فيلم
عثمان فيلم سعودي
حكيت الفيلم انا بلغه وباسلوب وبلهجه
محليه جدا فاسلوب الحياه في فيلم عثمان هو
سعودي جدا
فتوقعت انه الفيلم ما يكون واضح بشكل
صعب انه توصل رساله في فيلم قصير
النقطه اللي قبل كنت احاول اقول فيها انه
انه ثقافه كانت مختلفه ولكن وجدت ان
المتلقي الفرنسي يعني وصلته الفكره تماما
بدون اي حواجز فهذا كان شيء مفاجئ بالنسبه
للفكره او الرساله من الفيلم طبعا الفيلم
يحكي قصه حارس امن يعيش حياه رتيبه جدا
يكرر الاشياء كل يوم يحاول انه ما يخرج من
من دائره الراحه اللي هو فيها ولكنه يعيش
مع صديق وفاه فهد اللي هو نقيضه تماما
ففي شيء معين يحدث الفيلم يضطر فيه عثمان
انه يغير نمط حياتنا من جازان انضم الينا
المخرج السعودي خالد زيدان شكرا استاذ
خالد